speaking disgusting Sal is here JD
Richard and pop oh hi himself Gary BB
tea and all guys here are gonna go
through the computer and it's not what
do you have I have Gary at bottle rock
why is it you always have something on
Gary I've been on this panel a dozen
times I've never done a package about
you because I haven't done as much
stupid things as you that's why you
don't have things on it seems like you
all you have is when you talk about me
that's all you have there's a lot that's
like in it's like encyclopedias full of
stupid [ __ ] I try to strong-arm me too
so Gary's point I guess is that you're a
writer on the show you've been with the
show how many years 15 and out of the 15
most of the material has to do with Gary
right this was your decision ultimately
yes very good Gary because when I talked
to Sal about a sales whole rap is I
don't really want to do this Gary I love
you Gary comes in and he like pull some
mafia tactics on me moogan the butter uh
what is this bottle rock it's a music
wine festival out of Napa I'm one happy
celebrity jealous of [ __ ] that he
doesn't get now I don't know that's his
beef sounds very jealous in general I'm
finished you should especially me
because South thinks that that things
that I get to do he should be doing here
shitty horse race down to Florida or
some [ __ ] shitty toaster oven show in
[ __ ] Long Island come on town you
know that you're just looking to pick on
me you have a beef with me let's hear
the beef what is it go ahead say all
right but what happened he went to this
bar document okay
and he co-hosted the wrap-up show and
while he was out there at this huge
event this is a huge event right
what does Gary talk about he talks to
John Hyde about his l38 level pass to
the festival I mean why would you waste
valuable airtime talking about an
elitist thing like that what is it can I
hear the clip son of a [ __ ] did you
read your email no but you know that you
get is you have been selected for l38
but don't tell anyone
cuz everyone didn't get this back clip
soundex great clip great clip what else
my Gary let's here go on Carrie
alright then they're doing a show and
they're blowing off you're gonna hear it
fireworks are going off in the
background as they're broadcasting a
show again lack of production what do
you mean how do I can control that
I'll tell you how you control that right
go ahead you say what time the fireworks
go up okay we have to move it's a remote
let's move it indoors Howard you
wouldn't stand for that let me [ __ ] pack
shouldn't stand for oh come on let me
hear this eight eight eight seven eight
three seven six one zero that's number
two call John rasaan Gary Anderson east
Adam Richman I don't know what the heck
is going on there guy that's a weak
point I mean first of all that added to
the moment we could hear things going on
it's I'm calling it the way I see it I'm
sorry no I could take your third clip so
Gary was on the chef with this chef
Richard Blais very great chef as a
matter of I they were cooking ostrich
drumsticks with nitrogen of course
as Richard Blais is explaining what does
Gary do he coughs into the microphone
amir no one ever goes out to a
restaurant and they're thinking I want
to go eat some Mexican food he's better
you've been in radio for thirty this is
very weak hi Gary why don't you show Sal
how it's done what are you okay great I
have a wonderful package Gary you're
saying to me you called you a [ __ ]
microphone handle you have common sense
you put them now do you better produce
it for 30 years but you had to be make
sure that you were heard it's not hopped
into a microphone it's not a handout my
thirty years its radio I don't see how
we're getting anywhere we're trying to
see if Gary can do a better job because
quite frankly Salvi's were not strong
clips they're not strong clips Ben
there's a Gary showing Gary's an [ __ ]
all right Gary what do you have okay so
there's a guy that's a Division three
college baseball coach the school's
Washington to Jefferson College into
Pennsylvania the guy's name is Jeff
mountain after every game there's a
press conference which I'm surprised
Division three even has a press
conference break and they're actually
very well
horded yes so he makes sure after every
game to get in a reference about the
show go ahead so here he puts in a hit
him with the high okay we had two airs
that ending and we were able to to put
up a zero and then bounce back in the
fifth kind of hit him with a high in a
little bit well that's a real fan well
this is my favorite one because he lost
in the Division three World Series so
you think that like for this one jokes
would be off the table right but somehow
he gets in a reference to govern alleys
pizza Oh your father's pizzeria
obviously in Appleton we that was that
was a great experience as well really
miss govern Ally's pizzeria not being
around but yeah well we'll keep going
thanks ironically Sal doesn't miss that
place with all Haven said it like South
Pizza reott yeah by the way so that's
how it's done that's how you that's how
you present good Gary for once strong
clips they speak for themselves